[Music]
are you guys good taking it like this I
don't know you guys usually thank your
money
we're not gonna need your money you've
got more in that box and your father has
made in his entire life you want to risk
it on a drug deal we're taking it all
over you sit here on safe and cozy
risk-free we walk away with three
million
oh look we can't stick you where are we
going what is the last thing you
remember
I don't know what's your name oh I think
it's what he's been calling me just
bring anything back about this drug
dealer we took this from dirty cops
trying to kill us
and before we unloaded my uncle might
decide it's easier to kill us himself
than clean up a mess he'll open us up to
this you really should
you don't know who I am I know that guy
you got an hour tops to clean up we
don't pull the trigger unless he has the
cash anything goes wrong you're off the
hook
[Music]
I'm not off the hook when you're dead
clock is ticking
there is no bun back feel like I'm
running
why
[Music]